previously on the roommate Quinton makes
me feel like a desired man I feel a real
connection everything just feels right
seeing Justin with another potential
roommate makes me question everything we
have he told me off-camera that I was
the one but then he confessed to me that
he ordered takeout at my favorite place
with Quinta hey there uh you mind if I
steal him away I just don't trust her
okay
there's just something about her just
not being faithful what that's all I'm
gonna say
honestly I just need to know if he's
gonna live with me or Zack I don't
really care I just need to know at this
point I just don't know right Justin do
you like the way the bathroom smells
after you asked your client I would
prefer if you burn some sage I just want
someone I can trust
to pay the rent on time every month let
the games begin
the drama continues on the roommate
today I will make the hardest decision
of my life to live with my girlfriend
Quinta or my best friend Zack these past
weeks I've felt a really special
connection with Justin and I think he
did too
but if he chooses Quinta I I don't think
I could ever talk to him again I've got
to look at another apartment in like 20
minutes so I just hope this doesn't make
me late
I honestly don't know why are going to
this okay guys I have the final key here
and I'll need you to pick one of these
final two contestants to sign that lease
with you though thank you these past 29
weeks have been magical Zach we've had
some amazing time together
we've been every level of call of duty
and we've been Stoll of Entourage I
seriously if you use my turtle near my
Johnny Drama and Quinta you're my dream
come true
you like my cats if you lived here I
could see us throwing some pretty sick
ragers I could definitely see myself
spending the rest of my lease with you
however there can only be one
Quinta can I talk to you
what's going on I know you watched
animals walk Justin oh my god so what
doesn't matter you're broke a sacred
greed with him I don't know I just know
that he know we need to get someone on
that lease today fella no okay just make
that decision got that security deposit
in and sure you're lying to his face you
stop it is not that important okay
just chill so I did watch a few episodes
of Game of Thrones without Justin I
don't get it why is that acting like
this oh my god y'all are so annoying I'm
acting like this because Quinta is a
lying cheat she's gonna have to tell
Justin before I do okay yeah I'm just
alone shaking guys what what happened
what's going on
Quinta has something to say
Justin I watched three episodes of Game
of Thrones without you okay and I'm
sorry oh my god
Quinta how could you believe she would
do something like this to me I feel so
attracted I trusted her place beautiful
password I guess there's only one choice
Zak will you accept this key this is the
greatest day of my life
I get the roommate of my dream Zak he's
the one I know it yes tomorrow at 5:00
is that good for you okay
oh sorry hold on one second I knew this
is gonna happen and honestly I could
care less I've set up three meetings
with three future roommates tomorrow so
it's all good hey uh you know with the
shared bathroom at the new place right
wait what I'm sorry
No
my room
Zach I will be your